this is the Oasis I'm curious for a
movie going experience for each of you
that help change your life I it's easy
for me
what transformed me and made me want to
be a movie director was seeing for the
first time in first-run on a big screen
Lawrence of Arabia that changed my life
I went to the theater when actually rush
came out wrong hours movie and one of
the first time I watched a movie by
myself and I just completely escaped and
lost myself and I loved that films give
us the ability to do this I saw avatar
and in in IMAX for the first time when
it came out and I think it was that
point where I realized the craftsmanship
and the animation is not as well as the
beauty of cinema in Jurassic Park for me
is one of them I remember I'm just
really grateful that I got to see that
in the movie theater like the first time
and experience that and be a part of
that moment you know it's a part of the
American lexicon you know like the water
shaking and the glass I mean there's
things about you never forget catch me
if you can when I saw that movie I was
so surprised and it's a based honor real
surreal story yes so I was so surprised
I love the movie I got the adventures of
tintin which is my favorite animated
movie of all time because first of all
it's Steven Spielberg and I read the
comics I was a kid watching it come onto
the big screen was incredible for me I'm
gonna take the treasure of Sierra Madre
I'd like to just be there just mining
for gold somewhere up in them hills
that's the future I like to go to that
prom the under the sea ball and and
dance to go Johnny go go go there are a
lot of references in this movie a lot of
studios involved including Universal
Back to the Future and Disney with Star
Wars so was that was that a heart I
think it was difficult because we were
greedy about wanting so many cultural
references throughout the 80s and 90s
everybody cooperated in twinsanity Fox
and Universal and paramount and Sony and
Disney everybody basically came on board
to help us take their IPs and allow us
to create Easter eggs from their own
cultural phenomenons are you hoping like
a film like this inspires a younger
generation to go back and watch some of
these older
I hope so I hope to go see all the John
Hughes films again I hope they go see
the original Iron Giant the genius Brad
Bird animated film
[Music]
you